all right let's talk about your health
now the threat of contracting covet 19
is extremely high but sometimes
finding out if you've got it doesn't
happen as fast as you like well
there's a cova testing site here in town
that can give you results
in just 15 minutes they are excel
clinical research
take a look
so rapid testing is a simple diagnostic
test that allows us to check for
a couple disease processes a few of
these
are influenza a or b
covid and also rapid strep it's a really
good
indicator of infection
the sensitivity and specificity of
the rapid test is very high uh
approximately
96 percent and above so it's a very
accurate measure
of the testing you're just going to go
ahead and just pull down your mask for
me and just go ahead and tilt
your head back just a little bit our
staff is very gentle
with the testing and it you know some
people get a little tickle in their nose
and we try to go very very slow we have
a excellent technique
and which increases accuracy of the
testing
so it feels like you know a little
discomfort
but we try to be as gentle as possible
it's recommended only if you have
symptoms
however with that there's always caveats
if you are around someone or had
exposure
to a positive confirmed
case family member friend then and
you're
asymptomatic i would recommend that you
do get
tested in that case even though you're
asymptomatic
have no symptoms but do have a
exposure unlike other rapid testing
centers excel clinical research
takes walk-ins you do not need medical
health insurance for testing or a
physician order
all those barriers are what we're trying
to remove
from the testing process so it's a
complementary test that
exoclinical research provides to the
community
for rapid testing the test itself uh
results in 10 to 15 minutes
[Music]
but the the process is very quick
as well we do drive by testing
so you remain in your vehicle at your
option
you can remain
and wait while the test results come out
or you can leave and we will
send your test results to you by the
manner that you selected by email
by text or phone call when you get your
rapid test results at excel clinical
research it's important to go see your
doctor
if you don't have a physician we will
refer you to one
in our physician network so if someone's
interested in getting rapid testing they
would call our office or schedule
an appointment online we are open
and available seven days a week for
rapid testing
uh between the hours of seven a.m to
seven pm
clint excel clinical research is located
on south maryland parkway you can find
them online at excel research clinic dot
com
and right now don't forget this they are
offering a complimentary covered rapid
testing
in just 15 minutes all right las vegas
now we'll be right back